smiling on the way to an election but
rewind 30 months turn back the clock his
predecessor took a gamble the looks safe
but lost costing her majority opening
the way to two and a half years of
uncertainty which will now take another
election to try and undo Downing Street
keen for a pre-christmas election hoping
it will give them the majority they need
to deliver brexit and more but will it I
think it's three things that we should
be watching out for in the polls the
first is the leaf vote dividing again
for example voters moving on the leave
side from the Conservatives over to the
brexit party the second thing is the
remain vote this currently split uniting
behind one party either the labour or
the Liberal Democrats and I think the
third thing to watch out for is even if
that remain vote doesn't unite on a
national level it could unite on
different constituency levels so in a
constituency that Labor's more likely to
win voters move behind the Labour Party
and vice-versa for the Lib Dems polls
provide clues not answers these laters
you gave results show why number 10
wants to go to the country soon a
13-point Tory lead over labour breaking
it down the remain voters split few
support the Tories but it's neck and
neck between the Lib Dems and labour
then amongst leavers lots of support for
the Tories but a quarter still saying
they'll vote brexit party but this race
isn't a single national picture in
Scotland the SNP in a clear lead with
the Conservatives and labor quite behind
while in Wales Tory set to overtake
labour in an electoral earthquake but
does it translate into seats seat by
seat to call voting just one reason why
this election is so hard to predict and
don't forget in 2015
the pollsters got it wrong and then pond
and political parties got it wrong in
2017 and then there's Christmas to
contend with and that just looks like
it's gonna annoy the voters
so however obvious this election looks
like on paper nobody's taking anything
for granted
someone who's worked on Tory polling for
the last prime minister setting out what
Boris Johnson would need to do to
achieve his goal to the key group that
the Conservatives need to win is in the
north and the Midlands their
working-class voters they're older
they're more female than male 60% female
40% male and these are the sort of key
voters that voted labour in 2017 they
thought about voting conservative in
2017 but they didn't quite make it over
the line the talk from labour is about
advancing on the enemy but the party
must also mount a defensive battle in
every direction not only from the Tories
but also Lib Dems and the brexit party
take leave voting Don Valley in South
Yorkshire currently held by labor labor
like a youth leader but to be honest I
think he's just a mess up with all of
them none of them doing what we've asked
them to do to leave I would have voted
for labour because I am a labor person I
voted for labour last time and they've
let me down so I will not vote for
labour again this is an unusual election
the first December poll since 1923
that means the parties will campaign
differently postal votes will be key and
some candidates have even been boasting
they'll spend less time on the doorstep
than normal because of the dark an
election looks all but certain
everything else is not Sam Kate skinnies